[Music]
5 26 on your monday morning we had
updates on lane closures and there's an
app for that at ndot's ginormous i-15
and trop project so 24 7 closers of the
i-15 hov lanes between trop and just
south of the 215 that started last week
now the nevada department of
transportation advising of additional
off and on overnight lane reductions in
either direction except on weekends all
of the work is for the installation of
10 overhead signs in the area ndot
previously waited until near the end of
previous projects to put those bad boys
in now they say putting the signs in
first will help drivers keep up with
future road work
and yes there's an app for that now you
have to agree not to use it while
driving then you can check on the latest
road restrictions look at photos
videos and get the long-term
construction schedule
so we've got the links in the online
version of this story when you visit our
website and click traffic then driving
you crazy buckle up drive carefully and
please put down that phone you can join
the drive a new crazy conversation at
traffic eight at eightnewsnow.com